thank you s um so th those of you who
know me a little bit might be wondering
why I'm talking about large language
models and not Quantum
Computing you know it's such an exciting
exciting feel that I thought it would be
it would it would be remiss of me to not
try to step into it a little bit so um
okay so we have a we have a special year
on this on this topic coming up next
year uh starting for
24 and
uh uh you know as I said you know it it
does seem to be a quite a pivotal moment
in the history of computer science uh um
regardless of you know how far we
believe the revolution is going to go of
llms uh so at a practical level it's
it's very clear already you know given
what's been achieved and what we can see
coming that uh that llms are going to
have a Prof found effect on human
society um but um maybe there's you know
for me there's an even more interesting
reason to be interested in it uh um
because
um
um llms really
raise very fundamental scientific uh
questions about about the nature of uh
of uh human thought meaning the brain
and
computation uh
intelligence and Linguistics you know
the nature of linguistics so I'll say a
little bit more about it as we go along
and uh okay um and then there are also
these very urgent issues about uh about
uh uh uh responsible AI you know how to
make sure that uh that this sort of AI
is safe it's
interpretable uh fairness trust uh you
know what's called
alignment so uh so these are all really
important issues that that come up once
we once we start thinking about all this
so um since this was such an such an
important moment uh uh earlier this
summer we we put together a workshop on
large language models and
Transformers was end of end of the
summer it was um uh it was uh very
enthusiastically received by numerous
communities you know of course the
theoretical computer science Community
but the machine learning community and
then then there were others that
participated you know people from
physics from from cognitive science from
uh uh Linguistics Neuroscience um um and
so just to give you a little bit of a
flavor of it I'll I'll just say uh a
little bit about uh what happened at
this workshop and why why it was so so
interesting for people so um so uh uh
you know uh Yen Choy spoke about uh well
there was this very nice title possible
impossibilities and impossible
possibilities which which referred to
the fact that uh that you know we don't
yet understand the limits of these
models so you know are they you know
will they go well beyond what what they
do now you know are they just stochastic
parrots you know uh these these kinds of
questions uh uh Ilia who is one of the
you know Main architects of uh of LMS at
at openi spoke about uh gave a very
interesting somewhat theoretical talk
about the limits of
generalization but but the but the
theoretical talk was about about this
these theoretical Concepts that guided
his design of these Transformers his his
design choices as he was as he was
building these and in the panel
afterwards it was you know uh which
which included the agents IA Etc you
know it it it really gave us a sense
of um at least on with IIA just how
sincerely he believed that this was this
was going to go far you know that the
that the that the influence of this this
technology would would spread far and
wide uh sanjiv spoke about uh about uh
some some theoretical work about how do
you how do justify how do you how do you
actually understand that emergence
happens in these in these uh in these
models you know how do you get emerging
skills um B based on uh these so-called
scaling laws which which actually come
from from a physics like study of of
these models um miles granma gave a gave
a physics view of these of these uh of
of these uh of how how one can use these
models Pamela Samuelson who is our
colleague here gave a masterful talk
about copyright issues in in llm so
she's she's actually involved in some of
the um some of the legal cases involving
copyright uh in this and and um and she
laid
out in you know in this beautiful way
what what the lines are you know how you
think about these questions and it's
it's it was really quite an a in terms
of you know it's not how one would think
about about it naively um uh Nicholas
Carini spoke about uh you know uh about
about adversarial uh attacks on these
models and how you can adapt the usual
kinds of vision adversarial attacks to
these these
models Scott uh spoke about uh who who's
actually on on leave at open the ey
spoke about how you can Watermark these
large language models so uh if you want
to know if your if you're student turned
in homework written by llms you know
could you could you detect it and Steven
P padosi who is uh who's also our
colleague here uh spoke about um uh
meaning you know how how uh you know how
large language models are rewriting
Linguistics you know uh in terms of
chomski linguistics you know that that
uh maybe maybe those foundations are
just not not that uh well formed after
all and and moreover in addition to in
addition to uh to giving us a new view
on Linguistics they're also giving us a
new view of how meaning emerges from
language these are these are really
profound questions from from from
multiple different viewpoints
and um this is really what what the
Simons Institute uh you know excels at
is bringing people together who who can
study a subject from multiple different
viewpoints you know this is uh being
interdisciplinary in a you know on
steroids in in some sense and um the way
this this Workshop was received was also
quite quite remarkable um our colleagues
in machine learning were Were Somehow
you know to me it felt like they were
irrationally exuberant about the the
workshop uh you know they they sort of
felt that their uh conferences and
workshops they wish that they included
such a such a wide lens and so um So
based on based on all this we we decided
to put together a special year on on
large language models and Transformers
uh this is a little bit of a break in
two different ways uh from how the
Simons Institute usually functions one
is we usually do a semester long
programs and this is a a year-long
program so and the second is even though
we we you know we are fairly um
responsive and and do schedule things U
you know relatively quickly but but
there is still a waiting list you know
it's it we we usually schedule a couple
of years out but but this was such an
important moment that we we decided that
this really had to be scheduled as soon
as possible and so so it's happening
this coming
year uh so
um um so the the the way this will
function is the is the is the fall 2024
is co collocated uh with the with the
program on generalization which
uh and um this is a this is a very
fortunate uh collocation because
generalization is of course a key uh uh
question about you know that we need to
address with respect to llms and so you
know as with these uh with with with
these programs um you know we we start
with a boot camp and and uh a number of
workshops in this particular case uh
since we are so into disciplinary I
think the boot camp is going to play a
play a major role uh we we really hope
that um you know some of the basic
concepts here you know a Transformer
people usually many people think of this
as a very complicated concept it's
really a very simple concept if you lay
it out properly and so we are hoping
that we're going to going to be able to
do this in this boot camp and you know
make sure that everybody not not just
the people who are coming to this uh um
fresh but also for for for the experts
there's a there's a really clean clear
back backrop that's set up so that so
that our discussions can be focused
around it um um okay um let me since
since I'm I'm running on uh let let me
just uh okay so sorry let let me say a
little bit about about this before going
going on uh so in in terms of the in
terms of the Workshops the you know uh
um the the the workshops are on
Transformers as a computational model
where
where where we want to think about uh
things like uh scaling laws things like
um the efficiency of training uh you
know whether whether they are whether
one can use linear uh these very
efficient sampling based linear algebra
approaches to speed up this these
computations um uh there there's there's
a workshop on on trust alignment um
copyright issues uh um uh with llms and
then uh in the spring we have this we
have this workshop on uh which which
brings in these very foundational
questions having to do with uh the
nature of um you know the brain and
computation so and and and and
Linguistics so so here if if if I were
to say what what really uh what what I
find very compelling about
this so um
I I should make a make make a little bit
of a of a confession you know so this
this wasn't such an outof the blue thing
for me you know I've doubled in
computational learning theory before and
the question that always interested me
was was
was is there a computational model for
the brain and there were there were all
these beautiful models you know random
interconnect models uh of
neurons but eventually the kind of
functionality one they always led to was
was some sort of associative memory and
with llms for the first time you see how
how you can have a computational model
that makes makes sense out of imprecise
Concepts you know so word you know what
do words mean are they a platonic object
or you know but but with llms you make
sense of words as being you know even
though in real life words are have this
fuzzy boundaries but how do you ever a
reason about about these objects with
fuzzy boundaries and llms do that and so
it really feels like there's a there's a
you know one has a little bit of a tow
hold in terms of thinking about these
these issues and and U and there's of
course great excitement among
neuroscientists in terms of using these
models and thinking about them that's
that's one of the things we'll try to
bring into to this this Workshop oops
sorry okay so uh let me let me just try
to wrap up here so so there are a few
broad themes we want to we want to deal
with the broad umbrella already spoke
about there's another thing that
happened with respect to Theory and
machine learning about 15 years ago you
know the two sort of U seem to navigate
in different directions to the detriment
of both now with llms there's a there's
an opportunity to bring them back
together and that's what we want to try
to do at the Simons institute there's
also industry and Academia and how they
play in this in this particular space
because because compute time is such an
important thing and so you know where do
we find room for industry and Academia
to collaborate and and I think there
there is both in terms of alignment and
also in terms of generalization and so
what we're going to be doing is is uh
holding these many workshops which are
sort of one day workshops with a certain
theme in them for for them and the idea
is that
people like IIA and others who are
actually working on these in Industry
you know for whom it would not make
sense to come and spend the semester
here it would provide people like that
an opportunity to come and engage with
us at at an intense level for a short
period of time you know and that's
that's what we we'd like like to do to
make sure
that all the things that we are we are
doing here are in some sense aligned
with what's what what's actually being
built okay so
[Applause]
[Music]
stop 15 seconds for a question does
anyone have
anything will you address the recent I
guess executive order from the
administration about about limiting
computation and other things like that L
after reading
it
right next we have hung no who will tell
us about our current program on logic
and algorithms